what i know is that you're sitting on
some really fun information can you
share anything about like what's been
selling during this game yes
and i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do a plug
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
so we've got our last guest for today
dina bari
dina serves as stockx cmo a detroit
based online resale marketplace
dnet has demonstrated a history of
building beloved consumer brands having
served as a cmo for
three other companies including birchbox
we're super excited to have you dina
tina how are you
hello great to see you all together on
our happy hour
yes that's right well let's get right
into the thing i'm actually curious
about you've got a really epic
background what's what's on those
shelves anything interesting anything oh
my gosh anything i can flip on ebay you
do not believe how much commentary these
bookshelves get
um the big joke is this was actually
meant to be my house we moved to detroit
when i accepted this job right so we're
six months seven months into living in
michigan moved from california
and we set up this office because my
husband runs his own business and works
from home and
it took me about four weeks to take over
the office and the bookshelf
there's everything in here from you know
philosophy and yoga books to
um there's a book called cabin porn
right behind me
um and then all kinds of fiction from
all stages of our lives but
this this is the ultimate conversation
piece right here
how do you consider yourself how do you
view yourself as a leader
as since that's kind of the ethos of
this like
yeah and and like all of us we've all
evolved and gotten better what has been
the biggest
thing that you've closed the gap on in
your career
that you're just like happy you're like
wow i'm really glad i got better at this
because had i not
i don't think i could be the leader i am
today yeah well there i think there's
two things um and one of them i'm going
to echo what lockheed said just a little
while ago
you know the idea of being a thinker
that can combine left and right
parts of the brain i think in marketing
in particular that is a very valuable
skill um and hard to find so i think
that is
um something that i would say describes
my style
holistic thinker and somebody who likes
to synthesize and integrate
um and then i think the other thing is
just um
being empathetic being um a very
like holistic person in the sense of
like look we dina you're back
i think you're back i'm bad good great
sorry about that no worries
okay so um i'll just backtrack a little
bit you know the idea
i was talking about the idea of left and
right brain thinking coming together and
being an integrative thinker and then
um being somebody who really appreciates
and values the whole self
being brought to work and i show up that
way i want my team to show up that way
and i think as leaders today especially
in this climate it's so critically
important and and showing
your team that that's what you believe
in that's what you support
from them helps to bring out the best
the most creativity the best results
and the most present and committed work
what um what has really
been the biggest observation you've had
about being a leader during covid
because obviously
some of us are fortunate it's funny how
i just said that it was like a little
bit of a slip
fortune i was gonna say fortunate enough
to navigate through the great recession
or 9 11 or things that nature those are
not fortunate things but like
i definitely felt that we were in a
10-year window where a lot of people
were already at 32 years old in their
career and never been through anything
but hyper growth and i was like man one
day this is gonna hit and
so here we are thoughts on that yeah
totally i'm a huge
believer in the fact that um the
failures or the missteps or even the
things that are outside of your control
like macro events
um the challenges to make you better and
you know having lived through the great
recession
911 even having joined a startup that
was
a total bust you know and literally went
out of business um
those things i think make us more
resilient more adaptable
more creative and i think those are like
critical skills
in kobe 19 um you know
marketing and business so you know when
i think about
showing up for my team at stockx the
leadership team spends
a lot of time making sure that we are
keeping people together
keeping them connected a lot of people
are lonely isolated
confused you know all the negative
feelings and
um you know work can play a role in
combating that and leadership and teams
can play a role in combating that so
that's
i think one really important thread for
our company and for me personally is
just
being there for my team i think secondly
is
encouraging the adaptability the growth
mindset
again it's a it's a basic uh survival
skill right you got to be able to land
on your feet when
unforeseen circumstances present
themselves
and in marketing in particular there are
some
very new real constraints if you think
about experiential marketing
content these are these are areas that
really have relied on the in real life
experiences um to create what they
create and suddenly
those avenues are cut off and so it's
only the people who are
open-minded flexible willing to adapt
that can
not only survive but i think actually
come up with better ideas we've
our team has come up with new ways of
working in this environment that i think
we're going to bring with us
into the future into the normal when we
return to normal
um you know thinking more creatively
about how to
generate content in a scalable way that
reaches more people um taking events
that might have been activated in real
life and bringing them to a digital
forum
so that more people can participate like
these are really valuable
skills so um i think teams that are
focused on
being adaptable can actually grow
through this
so i've had the great fortune of knowing
josh very early on literally
one of the great misses of my
entrepreneurial investing career i was
not investing in stockx early on around
things that i love like flipping and
speakers and
now sports cards which you know has
super got me fired up yeah um
what i know is that you're sitting on
some really fun information can you
share anything about like what's been
selling during this year yes and i'm
gonna do i'm gonna do a plug
because we just published a media report
which has
is like a gold mine of fun facts but
it's called the stockx snapshot it's our
market movers and we talk about things
like andrea i need that immediately
andrea please
that should be in my inbox right now
like amy get on this i need that now
go ahead no um you know some fun facts
and i'm gonna cheat and refer to it but
um you know puzzles up almost 600
percent
um slides because who's going you know
who's going outside anymore right so
up almost 400 masks obviously at 300
percent
um you know slippers again
a big mover track pants like all the
stuff that we are
wearing every day right and then um i
think the other thing that we've seen
is a resurgence of what you might call
classic silhouettes and sneaker like i
think this is a time when people are
maybe
hesitant to splurge on that really
luxury item that
may or may not have enduring value but
you know the classic
silhouettes that have been relevant for
20 years that people are right
plus you know for the people that don't
collect and flip who actually
wear these incredible you know just the
dominance you have with sneakers
you know look let's call a spade a spade
for a lot of human beings
flexing with that impossible to get pair
of off-whites
when you go courtside to an nba game is
very much in the culture of this
and if you're not doing that maybe you
don't need to do that right this minute
100 and i think the other thing is you
know
the last dance like that has been an
amazing influence in our world
and and it's this beautiful convergence
right because i think a lot of people
you know we have such a diverse group
you know obviously
you and i can talk about this all day
explain even the last dance what that is
so the last dance is this amazing
documentary about
michael jordan and the bulls in their
attempt to win um their final
um championship nba championship and it
really talks about
you know the team it talks about michael
jordan and it talks about
um his brand as well and and in sneakers
you know his brand is
a force like potentially the biggest
force to be reckoned with
and what we've seen um you know actually
hbo released this pulled the release
date up
it was meant to be released later on and
then when kovid um came along and sports
were canceled i think they saw a big
window
um again sign of adaptability so they
released this early
and it was at a time when there was
nothing no nothing to watch on
on tv for a sports fan and so um it was
just brilliant timing and it was
actually brilliant marketing for stockx
we were not involved um
i keep saying that would have been a
dream a dream relationship during
partnership
but it still had this incredible effect
of reintroducing people
to jordan brand shoes and we've had some
of our best ever days
actually during this period which is
sort of hard to
believe you never would have predicted
that right in april and you're all
sitting at home and saying what does
this mean for business
um we've had records around certain
silhouettes that were released
in the past couple of months that have
become our best ever sellers
fastest ever sellers so i think it shows
you know back to the trends question
like the power of enduring classics and
in a time like this when there's
uncertainty and stress and
um you know recessionary forces like
people are spending money
on the things that have proven proven
value
stockx has done a nice job with content
series give everybody a little
context to that content yeah absolutely
well thanks for that
plug um we have an amazing team and
basically
you know their remit is to tell stories
that are relevant
um to our you know the products that we
sell so it's always
contextualized in our world of sneakers
sort of culturally relevant products and
the people the creators
who use those products to express
themselves
and so we have this whole network of
influencers musicians athletes
all kinds of creators that we um
collaborate with to tell stories and and
often the product
plays a role in that sometimes it
doesn't but we do make an effort to
bring it back so that it's um
related to what we're selling on the
platform and
um you know we use a mix of long form we
have these amazing you know almost
historical pieces we actually have
someone on our content team who's
a phd we have two phds and one of them
is a rap and hip-hop historian
and so he can write these amazing
long-form pieces about you know the
history of
sneakers through hip-hop culture um or
we have other pieces that are more seo
oriented
meant to drive results you know all the
shoes in the last dance
top ten jordan shoes um and then we
also have other forms you know video um
and we've been coming up with these more
soundbite written forms lately
um to just hear what it's like to be a
person a creator in barcelona a creator
in toronto you know as we grow more
globally in the community
become in many ways covet has you know
shrunk our world because we're all alone
more and at home more but it's also
expanded our world because we're online
and we're
you know the boundaries that previously
existed for physical interactions
have been raised so um you know we're
trying to lean into that and introduce
more of the cultural marketplace at the
global marketplace that is stockx to our
community
um and so we've come up with a few new
conceits during this time
one of them is on the line with which is
that short format interview with
creators around the world
and we're going to keep testing and
experimenting i think that's one thing
that is very much part of our dna as a
startup
and as a brand that's on the forefront
of culture
do you believe that every brand should
start thinking of themselves
more in the production of content as a
marketing
execution not just a maker of
commercials
and ads yes i think especially
in so the world that i live in is direct
to consumer
um you know i've spent 15 years in in
direct consumer startups and
um i think when you're building that
direct relationship with a consumer you
have to um provide context
you have to engage them in in a deeper
way than just a transactional
way and content plays a huge role to
show that
you have a voice you have a point of
view you have authority in the space
that you care about the issues the
customer cares about i think this is
part
of being a customer-centric brand and
business you talked about that on your
last
call you know i think brands that own
their channels and
aren't reliant on supply other sort of
distribution have that advantage where
they can
go really deep with a customer um and
that means you have the data but it also
means you have the relationship you have
the connective tissue with
um you know all the stories that you
tell you know what's
uh did when did you get to detroit i
moved here so i started
the job in september and i was commuting
believe this or not i was commuting from
california so i was flying here on
monday going home on thursday
and then my family and i relocated in
november
so right in the in the winter so what
was what was your favorite let's give
detroit a little love i know it was only
only like eight to ten weeks before or
for 12 14 weeks before covet hit but
what was your first observation i've
just really enjoyed
the resurrection of such a great city in
a lot of ways
um your your biggest observation for
d-town yeah i mean
there there is so much um
heart for detroit and one of the things
that i think is really remarkable is
just like when you come to detroit the
people who are here
are just so loving and they're like yes
we welcome
you a new person into our community and
we want you to survive and thrive here
because that's how we're gonna thrive
so that's one thing i mean the people
very welcome
they're just loving you know and they
want people to to participate in their
community which is awesome
um you know i spent a lot of time in my
first six weeks of the job
staying in hotels right in downtown
detroit
um and eating in restaurants so um
because i didn't have
a kitchen to cook in so i will do a
shout out for what
has become my favorite restaurant
downtown um which is laila
it's a lebanese restaurant and i'm
lebanese so it has special meaning to me
but it's like amazing food so real quick
real quick just for some fun so
you see a lebanese restaurant in you
know you know
i come from you know soviet russian just
that like where there's always that
thing is this gonna be as good as my
grandma's thing or my family saying like
are you are you like a tough critic of
lebanese food and it like surprised you
so did it surprise you did like like how
did that whole little
yes i am a tough critic and it did
surprise me
pleasantly um the dish that i always use
to judge is a simple one it's baba
ghanoush but it's like you know
sometimes it's those most simple things
where you can tell what's going on um
and but then it also has like a modern
flair so amazing cocktails amazing vibe
great service you know so you feel like
you're in a really cosmopolitan city
and like a world class um and we have
lived in new york and san francisco so
we we love that
um but they're spoiled with food yeah
we're spoiled but i will say the food
here in detroit has been really
fantastic so i'm pleasantly
surprised and eager to get back out
there and start eating my face off again
well thank you for being on we really
appreciate you thanks for having me
we'll talk soon
thank you bye youtube what's up it's
garyvee first of all thank you so much i
hope you're doing super well during
these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon